welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and marvel's moon knight released
new trailer footage giving us even more
context of oscar isaac's hero with many
voices and how those various accented
voices sound talking to each other take
a look steven
you weren't supposed to see any of this
what are you i'm sure you want to know
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my waking life and dreams
am i like some sort of secret agent
it's a little more complicated than that
wow as steven grant might say in this
promo you really can't spot some new
easter eggs can't shoo
gun shoot yeah that's right you're not
gonna get those ace con shoot puns from
that robot voice on tick tock so let's
break down the new stuff you missed so
the two identities of stephen grant and
mark spector chat in this storage unit
steven the awkward clumsy museum gift
shop employee with the british accent
finds these supplies hid in a duffel bag
of the badass mercenary mark spector
including his pistol some wads of cash
and an american passport actually this
is the same duffel bag that steven later
carries as he runs out of his storage
facility with the lights flickering
telling us that that golden egyptian
artifact that he finds may have
triggered the spirit of konshu to come
back down upon him now if you look
closely at that passport it lists the
name mark spector born in march 1987.
now moon night will probably take place
in the year 2025 in the mcu considering
hawkeye and spiderman no way home were
set during the holidays of 2024 and that
would make mark age 38 and we know that
for sure because the passport was issued
on december 14th 2018 expiration date
december 15 2028 since it's always 10
years later meaning mark got this
passport about seven months into the
blip which began in may 2018. so that
means mark spector did not blip and he
aged normally during those five years
speaking to steven from a reflection
mark says you weren't supposed to see
any of this it seems like his past life
as a mercenary was kept hidden until
steven found that cell phone ringing in
a crawl space with layla calling him
what's wrong with you mark why did you
call me mark and that's what led him to
unearth the rest of mark's gear i think
mark may have hidden this all from
stephen as a way to best protect his
body when mark would not have been in
the driver's seat to try to keep all of
this hidden from his old colleague
arthur harrow along with mark's stuff is
that golden snitch-esque artifact with
wings that pop out of the sides and we
saw arthur using this same artifact in
the other promo almost like a compass
the object hovering over his palm as it
pointing the way through the desert to
some hidden ruins i'm guessing this
artifact was left in the hands of mark
and that's why arthur tracked down
stephen this is the macguffin arthur
could be after since mcallen maui has
cited indiana jones as an influence this
could be like the headpiece of the staff
of ra and raiders of the lost ark the
relic that the explorers used to locate
the buried treasure now i am sure i am
reading into it but i like how this
talisman is made of gold but has some
jade green decoration on it much like
the color scheme of many of doctor
strange's relics the ivagamoto the
machina decadavis i will always be on
the lookout for ways moon knight could
connect to doctor strange's multiverse
madness even if moon knight's producers
claim it has no broader mcu connections
and that's because the next shot
immediately debunks that claim the best
shot yet of moon knight's full
transformation the double decker bus has
an ad for the grc that's the global
repatriation council first introduced in
the falcon the winter soldier an
international relief agency that
resettles people after the blip another
london ad for the grc actually showed up
on buildings in the opening minutes of
eternals the grc ad reads reuniting you
with your better half of course
referring to separated couples but here
ironically reflecting the way mark
specter's separate halves are connecting
in this moment he transforms from his
well-dressed mr knight identity into the
linen wrapped moon knight vigilante form
i pointed out in a recent video how
those wrappings both suspend a central
chest weapon but also covers some golden
metal breastplate pieces and now you can
see that they also cover golden shoulder
armor which slides up over his shoulder
from behind his back literally his whole
body is covered in armor beneath the
mummy wrappings now special thanks to
extra the world's largest smart wallet
brand for sponsoring this video extra
designs the smartest wallets in the
world which you can track with their
solar-powered tracker worldwide if you
ever have trouble finding your wallet
your tracker is here to help you find it
instantly it's voice activated and
solar-powered two hours of sunshine give
it a three-month charge so just download
the chippelo app on your phone and you
can ring your wallet from your phone or
your phone from your wallet even it
works with google home alexa and siri so
let's try it out here's my wallet
tracker going in oh a bird just snatched
it out of my hand
so
siri where's my wallet
it turns out birds don't listen to me so
i had to chase it down
but here it is found
and exer's wallets are just awesome
they're made of premium leather they
have rfid protection and you use this
little button on the side to instantly
fan out your cards so no more
overstuffed wallets no more giant lumps
in your back pocket so check out the
wallets with the link below and use
promo code rockstars for up to 15
off site wide at
shop.exter.comrockstars2 that's code new
rockstars to maximize your savings at
shop.exter.com
newrockstars2 and as moonlight steps
toward us the car to the right is
smoking as if his transformation might
have been triggered by a car accident in
the street and he pulls his weapon from
his chest and slides it right out of
those wrappings i love how when he's
done with it you really can just stick
it right back in there now also on his
legs you can see some egyptian
hieroglyphics there's a vertical line of
these hieroglyphics on the inner part of
his thigh and then a longer line on the
outer part of his thigh and it seems to
be mirrored on the other leg as well now
these are hard to make out and i am
definitely not an expert in egyptian
hieroglyphic translation but i'm still
gonna try on the inner thigh the top
letter looks like a bird with the long
tail which might be the symbol for a the
third one down looks like the symbol for
r the fifth one down looks like the lion
l and then after that the sixth looks
like the bird m and then three or four
other characters beneath that then we
see more footage of that mountainside
chase that looks like the bavarian alps
mark drives that von darrelman cupcake
truck as soldiers in arthur harrow's
cult chase him one soldier with cupcake
smeared on his face falls out the back
where you can see one of those cars
flipped over but a new close-up shows
mark mid-transformation again with it
looks like a hand around his collar
choking him and as he convulses his
vision intercuts with a purple haze
purple being the same color of the
lightning and the beams in the sky and
other footage when we see mr knight and
konshu and layla in egypt purple sorcery
in the mcu has previously been
associated with dark magic it was the
color of the magic of agatha harkness
dramu in the dark dimension and it could
all be rooted in the same source in the
mcu we will see but then a quick shot
shows a car slamming into the side of a
semi truck tag lj20f
not sure if this refers to anything but
there is a lockly comma jake identity
that we still have yet to see in any
footage another quick shot shows arthur
harrow in the desert slamming his staff
down like moses parting with the red sea
as armed soldiers appear behind him but
under his sleeves you can see some
silver cuffs if mark specter left their
past adventure possessed by the egyptian
moon deity of konchu arthur might now
carry the spirit of ra the egyptian sun
deity making him the sun king from the
moon night comics we see moon knight
leaping over the side of a ledge framed
in profile in the moonlight where his
hood is a pointed tip reflecting the
beaked skull of konshu just a very cool
wardrobe design there then one final new
overhead shot shows moon knight sliding
across the roof of a car slinging his
crescent weapons at two gunmen
throughout the shove notice his hood
just stays perfectly over his head so as
we watch this guy fight just some of the
aspects of his wardrobe are not gonna
adhere to the laws of physics just a
cool way of showing the spectral nature
of this hero he cannot be touched even
by wind resistance so that's everything
i spotted in this new promo can't wait
for this series to come out on march
30th you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at e-a-boss follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars for more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you